[Music]
all right I'll be honest I wasn't even
planning on reviewing these you know
it's Tech Timber there's there's a lot
of stuff going on right now like there's
other videos on other Tech that we're
actively working on that's coming soon
that you'll see so you know we saw the
new airpods announcement in the keynote
and the couple new features and then
Apple sent over a pair it's got my
memoji on it and everything I was like
that's cute but I promise you I didn't
even take it out the box for a few days
because I was so busy working on some of
the other stuff but then I did take it
out the box and I did try them
and I gotta say I I am now very
convinced that these are really good
but not by what you think so there's a
lot of small new features here that
airpods people have been waiting for for
a long time on the surface it's still in
a nearly identical design you recognize
them from a mile away the only way you
can tell them apart from the last
airpods Pro visually is by these dual
vents at the top but on the inside there
is an entirely new driver and amplifier
and these airpods do sound dramatically
better than the last ones easily the
best sounding earbuds Apple's ever made
there are way more lows and mids so if
you listen to Hip Hop or just music with
a lot of bass it's very noticeable it's
just way better and there's also very
little high volume Distortion and just
the whole sound profile is very
responsive and crisp they sound good
like really good earpods now there still
is no lossless audio with these but it's
still 16 bit 48 kilohertz audio and that
is good but that wasn't the thing that
convinced me it was a Difference Maker
for sure it's really nice but that's not
the thing these do now have a 33 longer
battery life so it's six hours on a
single charge now with noise
cancellation on and up to 30 total hours
with the battery in the case I promise
you I'll never have earbuds in for six
hours straight so this was more than
enough for me but it wasn't what
impressed me either there is also a new
extra small ear tip so now it comes with
the mediums installed by default and
then there's two sizes smaller and one
larger size so if you had smaller ears
that the previous airpods didn't quite
work with these may make a difference
for you with the extra small ear tip as
you can imagine that's not me mediums
all the way but some maybe even tempted
to say that the new case is the biggest
upgrade that's certainly what I thought
when I watched the keynote it's like
apple had a meeting about how wow people
are losing these things and getting them
mixed up with other people's airpods and
then they just decided to do something
about it so the case is the same size
and shape but there's this lanyard loop
on the side now in case you want to
attach it to something it's kind of like
the loop on the top of the water bottle
at mkbhd.com but just way smaller and
then you can use whatever language you
want to attach it to but if that's not
good enough for you there's a whole
speaker at the bottom of the case now
and it is surprisingly useful so it can
play a loud sound to help you find them
on top of the Precision finding that
already works really well since it has a
U1 chip inside so it's just like an air
tag if it's somewhere in your general
vicinity it can guide you to it that is
sweet it also plays a sound when you get
it on a charger wired or Wireless
and the magsafe ring helps it stay in
place on any magsafe wireless charging
puck that's not new but it also now
works with Apple watch Chargers too
which is a nice touch on top of all that
it is still ipx4 water resistant which
is an extra layer of security if you
work out and sweat around the case or if
you end up in the rain in these and you
can engrave it with your memoji now so
your friends will never accidentally
pick up your airpods case by mistake but
not even that is what was convincing me
about the airpods pro 2. not even the
most requested feature apparently this
is something lots of other earbuds have
had but volume control on the earbud
itself it's on the stock now so of
course it is now much more convenient to
just adjust the volume without having to
reach for your phone it's kind of like
this pinch gesture where you hold your
finger on one side and then slide with
the other on the flat spot on the stock
it's kind of awkward at first but you do
get used to it but no it was none of
that the thing that convinced me with
these headphones that they are
incredible is the H2 chip
so previous years generations of Apple
headphones have had the H1 chip inside
and it's this little chip that's doing
the audio processing noise cancellation
Etc this is the second generation of
that chip and apple is bragging on stage
that it has like a billion transistors
or something ridiculous whatever the
point of the chip is that it enables
everything that is special about these
new airpods so first of all there is
much improved active noise cancellation
Apple said something like up to two
times more background noise is removed
versus the last generation I don't know
about all that but combining these new
drivers and the sound profile with the
improved noise cancellation is
definitely noticeable I mean it's
incredible with white noise like air
conditioners and transportation you put
the headphones on and it just erases
them immediately like I'm not the type
of person to wear earbuds for an entire
flight I still much prefer over-the-ear
headphones for that but I get it with
these now I understand why people would
want to wear these earbuds on a plane
because they cancel is that well I'm
putting them on the same level of like
the Sony mark IV earbuds and right below
the new Bose quiet Comfort earbud twos
and I put them above the airpods Maxes
as far as how well it actually cancels
sound I mean they still sound very
different I did the back to back test
don't get me wrong you can tell the much
bigger driver makes a difference in the
airpods max but these get quieter they
remove more background noise now there
is already a lot of computational audio
happening in airpods Pro Sound they're
literally adjusting the EQ with
everything you listen to and across
every different volume level to make
sure they sound a certain way which is
kind of funny it actually makes them
hard to review sometimes against other
headphones because every track hits a
little bit different but the one huge
Advantage airpods have had for a long
time now over the competition over the
poses and the Samsungs and the pixel
buds of the world is the transparency
mode
as someone who has used them all like
the transparency mode from airpods has
for a while been on a level by itself
Above the Rest the real-time
pass-through of outside sound is kind of
amazing and in these with the H2 chip it
is leveled up again so on stage Apple
introduced what they're calling adaptive
transparency mode it's actually not a
separate mode it's still the
transparency mode which is with a
different name but what's happening is
it's still passing through all the
outside sound but anytime there's a loud
or a harsh sound above 85 decibels it
cuts that sound down to not be loud and
harsh so let's say you're walking or
biking through the city you need to keep
transparency mode on so you can hear the
cars and the people around you for
safety but you're still listening to
music or a podcast or whatever and then
an ambulance drives past you Sirens
blaring you will still hear the sirens
but that super loud sound will be
suppressed to a level that doesn't hurt
your ears it's just it's super smart
like and that ambulance could be
anything that could be uh someone
honking it could be a jackhammer
construction noise it could be a dog
barking but it's keeping it's keeping
the same sound signature of whatever
sound that is and just bringing it down
below a certain level and it's doing it
all in real time with virtually no DeLay
So the crazy number is it's sampling
outside sound 48 000 times per second
apparently that's 240 times faster than
the last generation and so it could even
be like a really sharp like quick
outside sound like a dog barking it will
actually reduce a loud dog barking as
fast as it's actually happening so by
the time it reaches your ears it's a
lower degree of sound it's crazy now
I've been trying it I've been walking
around with them and it's working really
well it's so good that this is this is a
real situation a scenario that I've
dreamed up that I believe could happen I
haven't tried this myself
but you know how you typically go to a
super loud concert and like front row
middle row like the speakers are
obviously too loud they're damaging your
ears if you have an Apple Watch it's
giving you like you know warnings that
you if you're in this type of sound for
too long it'll be damaging to your
hearing instead of wearing earplugs you
can actually you can really do this you
can wear airpods Pro 2 and put them in
transparency mode and it will take the
entire sound signature of that whole
thing you're listening to and it will
drop it down to a reasonable level
you'll still feel the bass in your chest
of the speakers but your hearing won't
be damaged as much because it's taking
all of that and reducing it and you're
still hearing the music
that's incredible so all this real-time
processing is happening on the earbuds
not on your phone and that is the H2
chip at work plus there's also a few
other features it enables too it talks
to the noise app on the Apple watch in
real time to show you how much noise is
being canceled out in case you want a
visual for that sort of thing and also
if you accidentally ever put the wrong
earbud in your case like someone else's
the speaker will actually play a chime
and you'll get a mismatched airpods
notification on your phone another nice
touch for those people who have
inevitably lost airpods to their friends
cases and probably don't even know it
and then there's a new ear scan for
personalized spatial audio this was kind
of a weird one so it's using the face ID
depth sensors to measure your head and
measure the depth of your ears to give
you a personalized spatial audio mix
Sony's been doing the same thing for a
little bit with some of their headphones
they use the front-facing camera
I don't know if I was uh convinced that
the usefulness of this I mean the
spatial audio was already pretty good
but after I did the personalized audio
basically for me it just sounded like
the Sound Stage got a little bit wider
maybe like there's just a bit more of a
spread to how far apart the different
sounds and instrumentals are
I don't know exactly how much of the ear
scan data was being used for this but
that's even more computational audio
thanks to the H2 chip overall though
these airpods are a significant upgrade
and they're just flat out better than I
expected I wasn't expecting this much of
a change and they sound way better they
work way better there is still lots of
other competition in the in the earbuds
World Samsung's buds are really good I
also really like the pixel buds I did a
whole separate video review of those if
you want to watch it you can check it
out with the card but at the beginning
of the video I said a little phrase I
don't know if you caught it but I said
airpods people
airpods people and this is something
that you might see a lot if you live in
a major city or where there's a lot of
mass transit or something like that it's
it's when people just wear air pods
everywhere they go like they walk around
the streets with them they bike around
they just live with airpods in their
ears and
these are going to be amazing for those
people like it's everything you'd care
about it's the better battery life it's
the better sound quality it's the better
noise cancellation and much better
transparency mode the better case the
volume control on the stocks all in one
package at the same price I get it I get
it it's really good airpods Pro 2
really really good and now you know why
all right that's it thanks for watching
catch in the next one peace
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]